One in five marriages in the world are between
first cousins.
The founders of Hewlett-Packard flipped a
coin to decide which of them would come first
in the company name.
The facial expressions on Lego figures have
become increasingly angry over the last 30
years.
A quarter of philosophers believe in zombies.
Alligators balance twigs on their noses, to
lure birds looking for nest-building materials.
1 in 3 children today can use a tablet before
they can speak.
Wine can be artificially 'aged' by passing
it through an electric field for three minutes.
John Lennon and George Harrison once got a
bus across Liverpool to visit a man who could
teach them the chord B7.
Toshers was a name for men who earned a living
by searching London's sewers for lost valuables.
An elephant call can be heard anywhere within
100 square miles.
By 2050, 70% of people will live in cities.
The pinstripe on a Rolls Royce is hand painted,
with no margin for error as the paint has
special properties which makes it instantly
bond to the underlying car paint.
The job is reserved for one man only, Mark
Court, his sole job is to paint that pinstripe
on every new Rolls Royce.
1 out of 10 passwords used on the Internet
are either 'Password', '123456' or '12345678'.
A newborn baby sucks in air with 50 times
the power of an adult.
People eating in a group of seven or more
eat twice as much as people eating alone.
It takes 700 grapes to make one bottle of
wine.